pendant des années londres nous avis ce
que nous devions faire maintenant c'est
à nous de décider pour une écosse
indépendante libérée du joug britannique
au pays du charbon la question est
épineuse le débat dure depuis 800 ans
mais il a été relancée dans les années
60 par le smp principal parti
nationaliste écossais à l'époque les
gisements pétroliers sont découverts en
mer du nord
les quoi s'il voit un enjeu économique
pour le smp
c'est une opportunité à saisir ce que
nous voulons c'est d'un statut
d'indépendance au sein du commonwealth
comme la nouvelle zélande le canada ou
l'australie
pensez vous que découvert du pétrole est
une influence directe sur ce courant
nationaliste sans aucun doute et cela a
accéléré le mouvement au delà de nos
espérances des années passent et le
débat est toujours d'actualité en 1992 à
l'occasion des élections législatives
britanniques
la fronde nationaliste écossaise prend
de l'ampleur même des personnalités
comme sean connery réclame
l'indépendance
sur le terrain les militants du snb font
campagne le parti nationaliste écossais
veut l'indépendance de l'école et
obtenir une place dans la communauté
européenne
c'est raté pour ce militant après la
victoire du parti conservateur
britannique en 1997
nouvelle désillusion pour le snp le
parti travailliste de tony blair
retourne au pouvoir avec une promesse
pour les cosses celle de lui créer un
parlement indépendant mais toujours son
autonomie économique
insuffisant estime le leader du snp alex
salmond
on y rit chez nous même notre pays et
non pas être dirigée par londres
indépendant en europe nous contre le
riom 97 % de nos finances dans le
contexte britannique actuel nous ne
contrôlons strictement rien le parlement
écossais c'est chose faite en 1999
et en 2007 première victoire pour le snp
le parti nationaliste remporte les
élections parlementaires écossaise avec
47 sièges de députés un vent nouveau
souffle désormais sur l'ecosse c'est en
tout cas ce qui ressort de façon
flagrante de cette élection
suite à cette victoire alex haldeman
devient le nouveau premier ministre
écossais avec toujours la même
revendication celle d'une écosse
indépendante en 2014
il organise un référendum d'un côté il
ya les partisans du oui ça vaut le coup
de prendre le risque
on doit saisir cette opportunité
maintenant et beaucoup de peuples dans
le monde n'ont pas cette chance de
pouvoir décider pour eux-mêmes
al'inverse d'autres sont contre cette
indépendance un divorce total c'est un
risque énorme
il n'y aura pas de retour en arrière si
les causes réalise que ça ne fonctionne
pas elle se retrouvera tout seul le nom
l'emportent 1 55%
le premier ministre alex salmond
démissionne remplacé par nicolas
sturgess suite au break site
la cheffe du gouvernement écossais veut
organiser un nouveau référendum sur
l'indépendance du pays en 2021
58% des écossais s'y disent favorables
selon un sondage publié en octobre 2020
[Musique]